Hi everyone, I'm Stefan from the Freewings flight school and today I'd like to tell you a bit about aerodynamics.
Aerodynamics in general, but mainly paraglider-specific.
The question that surely occupies all of us is why a paraglider flies at all.
It hasn't let go of me since the first moment I saw a paraglider as a child.
I'm always fascinated by why a paraglider made of fabric and a few lines, pulled out of a backpack, can lift us into the air and let us fly with it.
If you get to the bottom of it, you quickly find that a paraglider works exactly the same way as any aeroplane, like any bird too.
We have a wing that generates lift, which produces a force that keeps us in the air.
I sometimes compare it with a car: you can drive any car, but whether you really understand how the clutch and engine and everything works isn't usually the decisive thing.
With a paraglider too, you can be a super top pilot and not really know what's going on above you.
But I'm convinced that, when paragliding, it's relatively important
compared to car driving — that you also understand the technical background a bit, because it contributes to safety, and also, if you want to get the full performance out of the wing later when things get a bit more ambitious, having background knowledge about aerodynamics lets you get more out of your wing.
It all started a very, very long time ago.
Otto Lilienthal.
He started experimenting in 1891 and built the first, you can almost say, hang gliders, and even carried out the first successful flights.
He started early on observing birds and realised that not all birds need to flap their wings to stay in the air.
He mainly looked at the larger birds and noticed that they can glide quite well without doing anything.
And then he started taking storks apart, dissecting dead animals, and noticed that the wings of these animals all have a certain airfoil shape.
He then began transferring that wing profile to his own wings and discovered that you can generate lift that carries you into the air after just a few running steps.
In general, there are several attempts to explain, or reasons, why a wing flies.
Basically there are three approaches, or three principles, why a wing generates lift and keeps us in the air.
The first approach is Bernoulli's theory, and that has to do with fluid dynamics.
You can see here we have an airfoil section that, like most airfoils, is asymmetric.
That means there's more curvature on the top than on the bottom.
This causes the air on top to have to circulate faster, to flow faster, and that creates lower pressure.
On the underside of the wing, it's exactly the opposite.
There the airflow is slower and higher pressure builds up.
You can see the low-pressure and high-pressure regions are split into countless little forces.
Those are small force vectors.
If you bundle them all together and combine all the forces at one point, one resultant force emerges.
That is the lift that allows us to fly, the force that acts upward.
The split between them is a little tip for the theory exam.
The split is two-thirds low pressure on the upper surface and one-third high pressure on the lower surface.
It's a bit confusing wording-wise.
You have to watch out not to mix things up here.
At some point the flow stops following the profile and starts to separate back here.
We call that the separation point — back here it creates small turbulence and somewhat chaotic air.
We'll come back to that in detail later.
So in essence, Bernoulli's theory:
fluid dynamics, low pressure, high pressure — the first approach to why the wing flies.
Then the second is the recoil principle.
That's Newton's action equals reaction — he found out that on every body where some force acts, an opposing force is generated.
Maybe you've tried it: when you stick your hand out of a moving car —
perhaps not as the driver, perhaps as a passenger paying close attention to what exactly happens —
if you hold your hand straight out,
not much happens, you don't feel much drag, because the hand lies flat in the wind.
But if you tilt your hand a little, in that direction, there's a force that pulls upward.
And if you tilt it the other way, it pushes your hand downward instead.
And the wing actually uses this recoil principle too,
because the wing also has a certain angle to the oncoming air.
We call that the angle of attack — we'll come back to it later.
And this too generates a force that points upward and keeps us in the air.
The third approach for why a wing generates lift is the so-called circulation flow.
At the sharp trailing edge of the wing a starting vortex develops and that flow is deflected downward.
And this in turn gives a moment or force upward,
which also contributes to this dynamic lift.
So those are the three approaches that keep the wing in the air.
Now we come to a few technical terms regarding airfoils.
We're still looking at the wing in cross-section for the moment.
Later we'll look at the whole thing as a paraglider, the whole wing across the span,
and the lines and the pilot hanging underneath, and what influence that has.
For the moment we're just looking at the cross-section.
And on paragliders the profile is relatively thick.
You can see here, the profile thickness is the blue bar.
It's relatively thick compared to, for example, a fast aircraft —
a fighter jet, where the profile would be very flat, less asymmetric and rather thinner.
So slow aircraft, which already produce a lot of lift at a low launch speed,
without having to generate huge speed first,
are designed to be rather thick and asymmetric.
Chord length is essentially the distance from the front-most point to the rear-most point.
On the paraglider, leading edge and trailing edge — terms you know,
which you'll keep using again and again in flight practice.
Chord line is more of a theoretical term.
It's the straight line connecting the front-most and rear-most points.
Not to be confused with the chord length.
That's just the distance.
And the chord line is really the line connecting those two points.
Now we come to the forces and vectors.
I mentioned briefly that there are multiple force vectors on a wing because of this lift.
And these can all be summed up into one main vector, this lift vector.
Later we'll also learn
that this is the total aerodynamic force, composed of lift and drag.
But more on that later.
First, theoretically, how it looks with the vectors.
This is a classic theory exam question.
When you want to add forces together,
or when two different forces act on a body at the same point of application,
you can essentially chain these forces together.
You see an example here.
Forces F1 and F4 act on a body.
They have the same point of application.
What is the resultant R of the two forces?
So on the left you have F1 and F4 that you'd have to pick out.
Then you chain them together and see what the result is.
If you take F4 and attach it from the end point of F1,
and then connect the start point of both to the end point,
we see the result is a diagonal force
that has changed direction somewhat.
That's the sum of the two forces.
And in this example, that's R2.
Then we have another example right after.
If the forces act in the same direction,
it's of course even simpler.
Then there's no diagonal or anything,
you can just add the forces together.
In the exam, for example, you can count the squares here
and you see F1 plus F2.
Four squares plus two squares.
Gives you the three — wait, six — squares of R3.
But it can also be that the forces act in opposite directions.
And let's assume the forces are exactly equal in magnitude:
we have some stone here and a force pushes from each side.
If they are exactly equal, the stone stays exactly in place.
And here you see that F1, which is smaller,
weakens F3 a bit.
And again here, the sum:
you can add the forces together and the sum is then R4.
This basic knowledge is still important to understand the next few slides.
Here we again have a wing, with the chord line drawn in.
It's aerodynamically quite important.
We'll see that in a moment.
We have the total aerodynamic force I mentioned earlier.
We have lift and drag.
The absolute dream case would of course be
to build a wing
that generates no drag.
No air resistance, that is.
But that's simply not possible,
because we have a certain frontal area,
a certain surface that has to move against the air.
And that always creates drag.
However perfect a wing we build,
we'd never get rid of that small drag force
that acts against us.
We could never get rid of it completely.
And lift and drag combined,
you can see here too,
again form a triangle.
And its diagonal
is then the total aerodynamic force.
Still important — shown on the left —
lift and drag
are always at a 90-degree angle to each other.
They don't vary —
they are always at exactly 90 degrees.
Drag is always exactly in line with the airflow.
So along the flight path, or along the airflow.
It depends on how you look at it.
It actually doesn't really matter
whether the wing is in a wind tunnel,
completely theoretically,
or whether the wing glides through still air.
Ultimately it's always relative,
the wing against the air.
The centre of pressure is also important —
not to forget,
the centre of pressure is the point
where the sum of all these forces acts.
And the weight force
is always equal in magnitude
to the total aerodynamic force.
So if we're heavier,
we need more lift
and more drag,
and the total aerodynamic force grows too.
Then we go straight on with this slide
about the inflow direction
that I briefly mentioned earlier.
The inflow direction,
which runs in exactly the same direction
as drag.
And here we see the angle of attack.
That's the hand again,
which is somewhat at an angle,
slightly tilted in this air channel
or in this airflow.
And the angle of attack —
it's not the angle
from the horizontal to the airflow,
but always,
very important,
not to be confused —
the angle of attack is always
the angle of the wing,
i.e. of the chord line,
and the oncoming air.
And the oncoming air
is actually not horizontal,
because with a paraglider
you always have a slight sink.
That's why here too it's
drawn coming slightly from below,
because you always sink slightly,
if you simply look at neutral,
unmoving, still air.
Then we come to the drag
of a body.
What's interesting here:
the formulas for drag
and lift
are always exactly the same.
On the left there's W for drag (Widerstand),
after that we have a few factors
that complete the drag.
Very important here —
please don't be alarmed,
for the theory exam,
for the SHV theory exam,
you don't have to memorise formulas
or compute anything of this kind,
so don't panic.
I only drew the formulas
to show you
from which elements
the drag is ultimately
composed.
First we have the coefficient,
that's the shape and the angle of attack.
It depends on
whether it's a wing,
or a car,
or some stone in the wind.
It depends a lot on the shape,
how this device
or this object
is exposed to the wind stream.
Then we have the air density,
with this symbol,
here written as rho.
Air density is of course
very important too.
At sea level we don't have
the same air density
as up at 2,000 metres,
which of course
also influences the drag.
Then we have the velocity.
Careful — velocity
is always squared.
Its influence is squared.
We'll come back to that shortly,
what exactly that means
for us with the paraglider.
And S is the size,
i.e. the surface area of the object.
For lift it's exactly the same,
only the coefficient changes there.
The remaining factors
are the same.
Lift has a different coefficient
and thus it influences
the lift up front
or the force that arises
and then yields lift.
In the SHV exam questions,
a kind of example comes up
again and again.
What happens
if we have a certain surface area?
It causes a certain
drag in the wind.
What happens if we now
double or halve the area?
And there it's always relatively simple.
It's always linear.
So if you double
an object's area,
the drag doubles too.
If you halve it,
the drag is halved.
If the air density halves,
because you want to launch
much, much higher up, for example,
with the paraglider,
then the drag also halves.
A very, very big exclamation mark
applies to velocity.
When it comes to velocity,
everything behaves squared.
So if velocity doubles,
all these forces quadruple.
If velocity triples,
all these forces increase ninefold.
So with these questions you always need to make sure
not to,
make sure you don't make sloppy mistakes
and just click through quickly,
but look very carefully:
is it about some other factor
or is it about the velocity
of this airflow.
Very important
not to fall for that.
Here's exactly such an example.
I won't read the whole question out,
but if you have 30 km/h
with the surface area
in one case,
and in the second case
90 km/h,
then that's a tripling
of the wind speed
and a ninefold increase
of the drag.
So 100 newtons doesn't become
300 newtons, as you might guess,
but 900.
In our meteorology course
you'll learn lots
more important information
about the atmosphere
and the paraglider.
With the paraglider
it plays out this way:
higher up
we have less air density,
there are fewer air particles,
and our wing has to
move faster through the air
so it can generate the same lift.
That means, very simply put,
we need a higher launch speed.
You can see on this curve
that air pressure decreases with altitude.
At 5,500 metres
it's still
only half as much,
and along with air pressure
air density also decreases,
which appears in our formula.
Air density only halves
every 6,600 metres.
Be careful not to mix them up.
Watch out you don't confuse them.
But ultimately it doesn't really matter
whether it's 5,500
or 6,500 —
for the theory exam, of course it does,
but in practice it has the same effect.
The effect is
that air density decreases,
there are fewer air particles,
and somehow we have to
generate our lift,
because the problem is —
if you look at the formula —
the drag coefficient stays the same,
the surface area of our wing
stays the same,
our weight stays the same,
meaning the lift we need to generate
to get into the air,
that stays the same, but our density
is only half as much
or smaller.
That means up front, at A,
at the lift, to land at the same value,
we need to somehow compensate for that,
and the only way:
we have to do it through speed.
It works in our favour, of course,
that velocity is squared,
which means at half air density
we don't have to run twice as fast,
only by
the square root of 2.
That's getting almost
a bit too mathematical,
what it means is, if you launch from a high mountain
you need to be aware
that you have to run much faster,
which is usually a bit of a contradiction,
because you're probably already tired,
if maybe you hiked up,
maybe you're standing in deep snow,
maybe it drops off steeply in front,
so simply keep in mind:
we need more speed,
more speed also means a longer running distance.
On the other side, you shouldn't
forget the advantages either.
Up there it also tolerates
a bit more wind, because the air
thins out, so
there are also advantages — maybe
in a 30 km/h wind, as an experienced
pilot, you can still launch where
down at 1,500 metres
with 30 it would already be pretty demanding
and
a launch would no longer be possible.
Now we come back briefly
to these drag coefficients,
the Cd values.
As I said, it really depends on
what kind of object this is,
whether it's a wing or something else.
Important: when you
compare objects,
you should always start from the same
frontal area.
Now here, when you compare them,
they all produce a certain
drag when they're hit by air,
but some produce much more
than others. And that depends
on the Cd value on the left.
You can see, for example,
the half-shell is 13 times,
it produces 13 times more drag
than that teardrop
at the bottom of the list,
which only has a Cd of 0.1.
And here too there's
occasionally
a theory question:
how many times smaller is
a Cd value of 0.1
compared to an object
with a Cd value of 1.
And the answer would be: ten times smaller.
What I find interesting here
is the comparison
with nature.
Nature always tends to seek
the path of least resistance.
Whether it's a lightning strike
or a river winding through the landscape.
It always goes
with gravity and always
where it's easiest.
And if you look very closely,
it actually looks like
a raindrop. And a raindrop
doesn't come down from the sky
like a flat board, but
comes down from the sky in such a way
that it has the least drag possible and
can fall as easily as possible to the ground.
And this knowledge was
put to use early on
with these
wind measurements. Namely with
half-shells. If everything
were spheres or all flat discs
on such an anemometer,
it wouldn't really move.
Because then the force on all sides would be equal.
But because they are half-shells,
the wind that blows inside
causes much
more drag than the wind that blows on the outside.
And that's why
the wheel starts to turn.
And that can be converted
into a certain
speed. Here too, the formula
is shown below, which yields the drag.
When we fly,
we always have certain
changes in angle of attack.
Normally, if you simply let the wing
fly, it flies at
trim speed or at the
angle of attack at which the wing
is built. Or, depending on age,
when it ages and the line lengths are no longer
quite right, then the angle of attack
may become a bit greater. But you can also
influence it, for example by
applying brake or accelerating.
If you brake, the angle of attack
increases because you pull the trailing edge
down at the back, and the connection line
then from the rear-most point
to the front-most point
naturally
changes massively.
And flight speed
drops too, and thereby
the angle of attack simply becomes larger.
It looks roughly like this:
the wing flies slower,
Cd and Cl values
increase. That's very important
also for the theory exam, that you
remember: when the angle of attack increases,
the values increase.
Conversely, when we
accelerate the wing and
the angle of attack decreases,
then the Cd and Cl values
decrease.
Very important to know — we're actually always talking
about steady gliding flight.
Whether we're heavily braked
or accelerated, it's always
steady, and the wing
flies on a line, in a stable
state. And then, in
steady gliding flight, the yellow arrow
and the violet arrow — our force,
our total aerodynamic force
and weight force —
are always equal.
If we come out of full speed
and brake, you know
that the wing starts to climb,
converting speed into altitude. In this phase
our total aerodynamic force
is briefly somewhat
larger. Through this
we generate lift and briefly gain
altitude as well. But
then it settles again
and we're back in
steady gliding flight. And then
the two arrows, yellow and violet,
are equal again and we fly
stably and steadily.
Then we come to the stagnation point.
The stagnation point is the point on the wing
where the air
has to decide: do I go over the top
or under the bottom.
It's essentially the dividing point
where the flow splits.
And this point of course shifts,
it doesn't stay in the same place,
again to do with the angle of attack.
You can see this point —
if I increase
the angle of attack here,
this point migrates toward
the trailing edge.
And here you can also see why
the cell openings on a paraglider
are at the front
on the underside, and not just
straight ahead or on top.
Because in this range, where we
actually fly, we have our
stagnation point pretty much
exactly in this area, which is also
where the cell openings are — which makes total sense.
The separation point behaves
in exactly the opposite way:
when you brake more, the
separation point — where the flow
can no longer follow the profile — migrates further
toward the leading edge.
Until at some point the flow
up here separates completely,
the wing no longer generates lift,
deflates,
and we're in a full stall.
Right, that's pretty much
what happens with the stagnation point and the
separation point when we change our
angle of attack and brake
hard. Then we come
to the wingtip vortex and
to drag. We've talked a lot
about drag — now let's look at
the whole system and how drag
is roughly distributed on the paraglider,
on the flying system.
Profile drag, as you can see here,
is about 20%.
The lines are about 20%,
the pilot is about
20%, and the biggest
part, which is somewhat
hard to picture because it's the part
the eye doesn't see,
is induced drag.
And induced drag is produced
at the wingtip, because
we have the high pressure
and the low pressure, and these
pressure differences want to
equalise somehow.
Such an imbalance is
never good in nature
or in physics — it always wants
to balance itself out, and that produces
the vortex at the wingtip,
which can be quite strong
in some cases — so if
you fly very close behind another
paraglider, you'll notice
how it can shake you a bit.
On landing, definitely not
recommended to fly close together,
better to keep some distance.
The heavier the aircraft,
whether it's a paraglider or
a jumbo jet,
the stronger the wingtip vortices.
That means if you're flying behind
a tandem during landing,
you have to be very careful,
because the vortices there
are noticeably bigger than with
a solo wing.
Our goal — we said at the start —
the ideal case would actually be that we
have no drag at all and only lift.
How do we get a bit
closer to that? With the profile
we can get some gains,
because
if you look at the wing,
it has lots of
waves and bumps because of the cells, which
actually — if you look at aeroplanes,
where the surface is nice and smooth — is
actually inefficient and not so favourable.
That's why on high-performance wings
or intermediate wings,
the further you go up the difficulty class,
the more cells
these wings have. And these cells make
the waves
as
flat as possible — better
many tiny waves than
big humps. That gets you
much closer to the desired
ideal profile. But it requires
that you can still control the device,
because it just becomes much harder
to fly. Induced drag
is reduced via aspect ratio.
On aeroplanes there are also
those winglets you see,
which go up at the wingtip,
to reduce that vortex.
On the paraglider you mainly tackle it
through aspect ratio.
We'll come back to aspect ratio
later — it's basically
a wider span and
a smaller chord. So,
the more the paraglider looks like a
sickle in the sky and looks nice
and slender, the more
optimised the induced drag is.
Next are the lines.
Here ideally you want
as few and as
thin lines as possible.
That also brings with it
more knots, that it's
more demanding to fly in case of
a disturbance, and so on.
So you see, all these factors
actually mean
that the wing becomes harder to fly
and requires much more skill.
And last but not least,
the pilot
also makes a big difference, of course —
whether we sit upright inside
and present a large area
to the wind, or whether we
lie thin and as small as possible.
That again accounts for
a few percent we can
optimise. Here, quickly
sketched, is roughly how a prone harness
would look in the wind tunnel.
So here too you see, in front
as rounded as possible, so that
the air that has hit it
flows around
nicely, like a raindrop.
Then it flows nicely behind.
Ideally
the harness behind
tapers into a point
and is not suddenly sharp-edged,
where the flow separates, but
really runs into a slit
or to a point at the back
and then comes back together behind,
so that as little
turbulence as possible occurs back there.
And that's how here too
you can get the maximum.
So the foot bag is not just
to be nice and comfortable and warm,
it's really also
aerodynamically a fairly big
difference, but again
more demanding to fly.
Now we come to the terminology.
First we talk
about wing span,
and it's important to know that
all these
measurements we're
talking about, on a paraglider
always come in flat and projected.
Because laid out flat, a
wing is much bigger than
when it's in the air.
So the outermost two points
measured in the air are a bit smaller
than when the wing lies flat on the ground.
And what's ultimately aerodynamically
interesting, this area
that we have in the air above our heads
measured there, that generates
lift, is always the projected
area. But you
sometimes have to watch out
to make sure you're talking about the same thing, when
someone says, oh you've got the 20 m²
and the other
says no, the 18 — if it's not
the same measurement being discussed,
then in some cases
it can actually be the same paraglider.
Because one is talking about flat (laid-out)
span or area and the other
is talking about projected.
Then here we're at chord length.
Here we actually always talk about
the mean chord, because
the chord at the stabilo here
is much smaller
than in the middle, and that's why
an average is computed
and then we actually speak of this
mean chord.
It's the chord that
ultimately makes a wing more efficient,
because as we've seen,
induced drag is the
largest drag, and with aspect ratio
you can bring it down a bit.
That's the ratio of span
to mean chord.
The mean chord can't simply
be measured out — it's
a value given by the manufacturer.
You can, if you
look at the fraction here — on top
span divided by
mean chord —
you can also expand the fraction
with span on top,
span on the bottom too, and then
at the bottom you get span
squared divided by area.
So either span
divided by mean chord
or span
squared divided by area.
That gives the same value
under the line, and that's your
aspect ratio of the wing.
Here briefly the explanation again —
projected area is,
exaggerated, like if
someone shone a torch on it
or, even better, the sun shone on it,
which is of course much further away —
if you're right by the landing field
or, say, near a windsock, where you could
look and see how big the shadow is.
That would roughly be the projected
area, just to explain it.